so you have said that you save the prime
persona for football who is Prime who is
Deon um Dion is kind of recluse um
calm very uh introverted really really
very introverted country boy with a city
swag um love the
fish loves uh anonymity if you could
believe it um wow I want to pause there
because I think there will likely be a
lot of people that don't believe that
like anonymity and very reclus I I don't
like crowds okay I I know how to show
out in the crowd but I don't really like
crowds I don't really function well in
crowds and you you don't catch me in
crowds most unless I'm in a game but you
won't never see me in that realm uh
Prime is totally different Prime is that
Alter Ego that we all have that I've
just have had an opportunity to enact to
really put some legs on and make make
him work because I told my mother you
know when I was seven she I was going to
make a lot of money she was going to
never have to work and I saw way back
then defensive backs they wouldn't
slotted to do that so I had to create
something that I know would and I
created this character in my dormatory
room in Florida State and I just fed him
and fed him and fed him and fed him and
perfected him and uh it is what it is so
now I'm I'm probably a blend of both
right now cuz I went from Prime time to
just Prime now coach Prime it's like I'm
in the third quarter and I'm winning and
I'm high stepping so in some ways was
Prime sort of a Persona that you had to
adopt to be able to be different from um
no it's something I had to adopt to
command the resources that I promised my
mother quarterbacks and defensive backs
at that time didn't even make a
meal um Prime made us a meal the first
ever in the history of the NFL then the
first 2 million and the first four
million then it just kept going crazy so
I'm thankful and I'm appreciative but
you got to understand I I you can't get
caught up in trick or
treat 365 days a year you you can't do
that cuz you sooner or later you got to
take your costume and your mask off and
be who you are but see that's the thing
I I know who I am like at this age and
Stage probably for the last 20 years I
found my location and I know who I am
what I am how I am where I'm going and I
know how to get there so going off that
way back in I think 1989 was when you
said they don't pay me to be humble
right now it feels like there are people
that are almost calling for you to be
that yeah why is this idea of knowing
who you are not necessarily being humble
one of the things that propels you
um when I said that that was because I
was I was a grown dog out there on that
field like I'm not going to be humble
about what I got in the gifts that I
have I ain't never seen nobody open a
present on Christmas and say oh that was
so sweet no oh you see what I got yeah I
I got a gift that I've opened and I'm
thankful and proud of it you don't think
I'm going to shout and rejoice and and
and and and do my thing because of this
gift that God has given me no that's
what I meant by that I got a tremendous
gift and I Know It gift and I perfected
it but hard work focus in
dedication I also think when you're good
at something and you know you're good at
that thing for whatever reason it makes
people uncomfortable if you vocalize
that you're good at something and that
speaks to that insecurity maybe people
feel when they're talking to you because
you're like well wait a minute he
supposed to not be all of this because I
don't feel like I'm all of this their
lies the quote don't allow my confidence
to offend your insecurity their lies to
quote that's where that quote derived
from and I can't I can't I ain't got
nothing to do with that whatever you
going through because I'm going to be me
and I'm mandated to be me um I'm
pleasing God not man now if I'm pleasing
God and God is having you tripping
that's a problem with you that ain't me
because I all I want to hear God say is
well done my faithful servant and I've
heard him say that a m icity of times so
you got a problem and that ain't on me
that's on you it ain't on me that's on
you yeah so you did this article in the
80s and I want to read the quote to you
going back to the80s it's a great quote
that applies to you right now which is
why I loved reading it so much so this
is an a Sports Illustrated article you
said all my life I've been the man I've
been in the spotlight at every level
it's just a bigger Spotlight I learned
the system in college how do you think
defensive backs get attention how do you
think think Jim McMahon made so many
millions they don't pay anybody to be
humble some people will come out to see
me do well some people will come out to
see me get run over but love me or hate
me they're going to come out wow I'm a
businessman now and the product is me
Prime Time God that's good some can you
put some hand claps in the edit Ed
absolutely give it up God that was a
that was a young Prime but and I say
this to illustrate that this person you
are now is in so many ways who you have
always been true what comes to your mind
hearing that over 30 years later wisdom
I didn't know I had that type of wisdom
at that age because what people wanted
to see was Prime I could remember and
I'm not going to call the gentleman's
name very popular um uh personality
television personality interviewed me in
San Francisco I mean I'm defense player
of the year we winning you know super B
bound and he wanted the interview
Prime and I gave him
Dion that interview never aired cuz I
didn't give him what he
wanted I gave him D but he didn't want
that you should just told me he want
that and not just come to interview me
and that never aired so I looked at him
Sideways from then home yeah yeah said
so you you just wanted the puppet show
that's all you wanted you ain't want to
get it no me cuz I'm trying to get you
me but you don't want me you want Prime
you should said that you wanted the
Persona instead of the thing that was
real genuine right